welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and moon knight explores the
terrifying reality of how it would feel
if someone else lived our weekends for
us what day is it today sunday sir no
episode one shows steven grant realizing
that he actually shares his life with
the mercenary mark spectre causing
steven to feel like he's chaotically
leaping forward in time from his point
of view and our point of view this
results in the bigger story elements of
the show unfolding off screen leaving
steven and us guessing as to how we got
there will the show ever replay the
events of episode 1 but from mark's
perspective well in this video i am
going to break down and reconstruct the
specific chronology of mark's weekend
really the five days that encompassed
this first episode what exactly mark did
off-screen each time we blacked out and
jumped ahead forensically figuring that
out based off of clues and that crime
scene afterwards all to try to figure
out what's really going on in this
series and a reminder that the best way
to support us here at new rock stars is
to grab one of our latest obsession
shirts inspired by moon knight tomb of
the moon god already selling out fast
over at
newrockstarsmerch.com okay when we start
with steven it's thursday morning now
how do we know it's thursday because at
the museum dylan reminds steven about
their date coming the next day just
checking me still on for seven tomorrow
now steven has no memory of setting this
up so it must have been something done
by his other identity sometime before
thursday actually lots happened before
thursday mark must have set up steven in
his flat in london and got him a job as
a museum gift shop employee something he
did months previously according to
layla's line later i've been texting and
calling you for months and since steven
was already in the routine of strapping
his ankles sanding the floor taping the
door that suggests mark must have taken
over steven's body in the past and
caused him to wake up in strange places
several times previously during those
pre-thursday outings mark likely set up
his storage unit and set up whatever was
going on with mum perhaps a fake
voicemail inbox and mailed postcards to
steven to keep up that charade now it
remains a mystery who asked out dylan
because if it was mark wouldn't dylan
have noticed the guy having an american
accent suddenly switching to a british
one when she talked to him on thursday
would dylan have thought steven might
have been doing an american swagger
accent to flirt with her but really if
mark's priority was to steal the scarab
that weekend why would he have set up a
date with dylan on friday night i mean
maybe it was a last-minute opportunity
that came up maybe mark thought he could
get that scarab on friday and make it
back to london in time for a celebration
dinner with dylan i don't know but it is
possible that there is another british
accented identity who actually flirted
with dylan and set up that date like the
jake lockley cab driver identity someone
we have not yet met now back to thursday
we saw all the thursday events from
stephen's perspective his morning
routine feeding gus calling mom his
commute his day at work with donna
chatting with crowley in the park his
bedtime routine but then before he even
falls asleep he suddenly wakes up face
first jaw dislocated in the alpine
village so this means back on thursday
night mark took over geared up in his
storage unit and then on friday traveled
to the alps his mission disrupt an
exchange with harrow's cult to acquire
the scarab and that's according to the
henchman later there was a problem with
the exchange we got ambushed someone
killed two of our men ah so this means
some other mystery dealer was selling
that scarab to hero's cult in that
castle in the alps that could even be
why harrow and his cult members were in
this town at that moment so mark
interfered with that exchange he killed
two of heroes men he took the scarab and
he jumped out the window and perhaps
mark thought he could summon the suit on
the way down but it didn't work and when
he hit the ground steven took back over
so then we see friday from steven's
perspective when he flees the henchmen
into the town he witnesses the emmett
ritual and he gets recognized by a hero
i know you
me mercenary ah so this means that mark
must have had some run-ins with harrow
in the past and that he might even move
to london to be close to harrow's london
home base to continually foil his
operations but you know what i don't
talk enough about in these videos the
hair it is pretty important i mean sure
lots of guys look great with a bald head
samuel lil jackson patrick stewart
silver surfer but if you're concerned
you won't be able to pull off the look
quite as well as they can keeps can help
you out two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 but with
keeps you can get quality expert care
without ever visiting a doctor's office
or pharmacy keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there but at half
the cost of your local pharmacy though
you never have to go into a doctor's
office keeps is a network of expert
medical advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your goals a reality easily subscribe to
keeps and get refill reminders so you
never run low on the products you need
to take care of your hair hair loss
stops with keeps to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com new
rockstars or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars so anyway
steven is eventually tackled by these
four henchmen who include a woman with
blonde hair a young guy with a shaved
head a bearded man and then this older
balding man who was in the store
previously he's wearing a blue shirt and
an apron but he comes out and joins the
dog pile that guy is the one who prized
the scarab from steven's fingers and
then stephen blacks out again to
suddenly see all four of these people
dead and that bloody scarab back in
steven's hand so let us now do some
forensic work to figure out what just
happened three of those four henchmen's
heads are visible in frame and all three
have huge pools of blood pouring out as
if they've been shot or stabbed in the
head or had their heads bashed against
those cobblestones but that apron guy
the one who grabbed the scarab is
largely out of frame but based on that
blood in steven's hand mark likely pried
that scarab out of the man's hands maybe
even breaking off and severing the guy's
fingers to do it maybe even moon knight
sliced off the guy's hands because that
much blood must have come from some kind
of laceration really the weirdest thing
to me about this crime scene are the
bystanders there's one woman on the left
and then a woman and her daughter on the
right what were these three doing
moments before because presumably
they're part of the cult it seems like
everyone in this town is part of the
cult and they might have gathered in
this moment to see harrow pass emmett's
judgment on mark when he was captured so
then mark had to have disposed these
four henchmen super fast and super
brutally so then steven after the fight
escapes to town in that cupcake delivery
van swerving on the switchbacks all set
to wham and then one of the henchmen
boards the truck with a gun he struggles
with stephen stephen shoves the cupcake
in his face another car pulls up and
then blackout the other side of it the
henchman is now dead bleeding from the
head and blood is on steven's face so
this means that mark must have grabbed
the gun from that henchman
shot him in the head in close range
spraying his own face and then shot the
driver of the other car the shooter of
that car must have shot out mark's
windshield in the side window so that
when steven wakes up that dead henchman
falls back out of the van and then that
card that he shot at swerves and flips
steven has to swerve around a log truck
setting into motion the whole mousetrap
of the cascading logs down the hill
which come back later at this point one
sedan and one suv wedged steven and then
another blackout so that steven is
suddenly driving backwards so during
that blackout mark must have rammed into
the smaller car not the suv which makes
sense it is the smaller car you could
tell by that red pink paint on the
damaged side of that sedan this caused
them both to spin out and then mark to
spin backwards and then decide to put
the van in reverse at this point he
picked up the gun that stephen had
dropped and then shot the driver of that
sedan through his own shot open
windshield so now with steven back in
control the sedan drives off the cliff
the scv rams steven and steven spins
back forward stalls out so that when the
scv driver stop to kill him they are
then crushed by the logs from before and
if you look closely so is steven those
logs wipe them out like its final
destination too so steven blacked out
here but mark would not have had time to
get out of the way of those logs that
means mark powered up into moon knight's
warrior form from the bottom of that log
pile smashed out from the logs and then
returned to the uk stashed the skirb in
a storage unit and this all happened on
saturday because the pet shop owner says
that she saw mark on saturday if you
want to swap it go ahead but like i said
yesterday wasn't here yesterday yeah all
right so it must have been saturday when
mark replaced gus why did he need to
replace gus maybe gus died when he
wasn't fed maybe diabetes overfed maybe
just died from natural causes they're
goldfish it happens but saturday was
when mark replaced the tape replaced the
sand replaced the leg harness and went
back to bed so then stephen wakes up on
sunday afternoon he thinks it's friday
morning and based on him casually eating
cereal i'm guessing he actually has
fridays off from work which might be why
mark planned to slip away on that
mission on friday then at the pet store
he sees that it's 505 in the afternoon
and then rushes home for his date at
seven he sits at that steakhouse from
seven until the kitchen closes so
presumably like 10 or 11. and then only
after that three or four hours of
waiting around as he finally called
dylan take time i ate steak by myself
thanks two days ago
what what i thought we said friday today
welcome to sunday and then things get
really weird at this point it is late
sunday close to midnight if that
restaurant just closed and then stephen
had to wait for a steak to be overcooked
to be well done at this point late on
sunday steven finds the burner phone he
talks to layla he tries to flee his
apartment but then that old woman takes
the elevator to the fifth floor to visit
a friend and again this is at midnight
on a sunday okay and then conscious
scares stephen and then he blacks that
again to the bus the next day monday so
that means that after that moment with
koncho on the elevator
mark assumed the body late sunday night
and then for some reason the next day
ended up on a bus with arthur harrow why
wouldn't mark want to get as far away
from harrow as possible well we know
that marcus hidden the scarab so he's
not worried about harrow getting that
from him he might now be trying to lure
harrow away from steven's workplace
because steven said that he worked at a
museum in london but on that bus stephen
wakes up he gets off the bus diverting
from where mark wanted to go and then
accidentally leads harrow directly to
the museum where later harrah releases
the jackal on stephen to try to get the
scare back and then steven allows mark
to take over the body mark someone's a
moon knight suit takes care of business
and that's where we end episode one so
when we reconstruct this chronology we
can draw two conclusions at least one we
know that mark is an active mercenary
using steven grant as a cover identity
as mark actively disrupts the plans of
arthur harrow's cult in the alps and in
london it was mark's fault going after
harrow that got stephen in this trouble
and key to harrow's plays are obviously
the scarab which hero likely wants to
use to resurrect ahmet and mark and
konshu cannot let that happen the second
conclusion you realize when you
reconstruct this chronology is that
stuff is happening at random times
during the day and it does not make
sense when you applied the basic
chronology how long it would take people
to get from a to b how long people would
wait places who would know what when so
much does not add up in this chronology
which is why i'm so stuck on this idea
that much of what we are seeing may be
coming from an unreliable narrator and
even the stuff we see on screen may not
be objective reality anyway hopefully in
future episodes we spend a bit more time
watching mark be that merc because while
it is fun to clean up blood it's also
fun to spill it you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
rockstar subscribe to rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you